quake cones opening ceremony has wrapped
which means we have a ton of news from
Bethesda I'm Tony and this is your jam
packed gamespot news update first up all
the new trailers preto shows off Space
Station exploration and a bunch of alien
monsters will be going up against it
also features narration from protagonist
Morgan you giving us a hint at the
game's story quake champions also
received a gameplay trailer featuring
classic weapons like shotguns rail guns
and rocket launchers it's fast it's
frantic and a beta is coming in 2017 as
for games you can play right away dooms
first DLC pack unto the evil released
early and it's available now this
includes three new maps a new weapon
item and playable demon and new armor
and taunts unto the evil is 15 bucks by
itself or included with dooms $40 season
pass finally the open beta for Elder
Scrolls legends has launched on pc mac
ios and android versions of the full
game are also on the way these are the
biggest headlines from quake Collins
opening ceremony but the convention
isn't over yet keep an eye on gamespot
for more announcements from the show
floor and various panels and for all the
latest from Bethesda you're already in
the right place